terminé et bien
c'est bon
une équipe qui rassemble tout le pays
depuis plusieurs semaines des joueurs de
soccer qui déjà espirt une nouvelle
génération
prochaine étape ce vendredi 1er avril
alors qu aura lieu le tirage au sort des
groupes pour la phase finale de la coupe
du monde de soccer
le canada occupe actuellement le 33e
rang du classement de la fifa jamais
dans son histoire et qui sait ce que
cette jeune équipe sans complexe pour
accomplir si le tirage lui est favorable
en 1986 lors de la dernière et seule
participation canadienne à la grande
messe du poker le canada avait subi
trois défaites en trois matches il
n'avait pas marqué un seul but contre la
france la hongrie et l'union soviétique
cette fois par contre les canadiens
n'arrivent plus en néophyte
l'information fait parler d'elle sur la
scène internationale le canada compte
dans ses rangs des vedettes
internationales comme alfonso belize et
jonathan david et ses récentes victoires
en phase qualificative contre les états
unis et le mexique ont envoyé le message
qu'ils ne seront pas au qatar en
figurant comme c'était le cas au mexique
il ya 36 ans
les yeux du monde entier surtout drôle
davantage prochainement vers le pays
hôte où le contexte socio politique n'a
rien de reluisant
après les accusations de corruption lors
de l'obtention du tournoi le pays s'est
transformé en véritable chantier de
construction des chantiers où la main
d'oeuvre est composée à 90% de
travailleurs étrangers et c'est le sort
de ces derniers qui demeure sous la
loupe internationale alors que pleuvent
les accusations de maltraitances et
d'esclavagisme j'en appelle au
boycottage
les premiers matchs auront lieu à la fin
du mois de novembre prochain ici michael
roy radio canada montréal